字幕: Rychelle Brittain
校正: Moe Shoji
早速なんですけど 皆さんちょっと
協力してほしいことがあります
今から皆さんが
好きで好きでしょうがないもの
ぜひ ちょっと
想像してみてほしいんですね
目をつぶっていただいてもいいです
食べ物でもいいです
飲み物でもいいです
好きなあの子のことでもいいです
趣味でもいいです
どうですか？
ちょっとワクワクしてきたかもという人？
いいですね
ありがとうございます
ちょっと隣の人に
話したくなってきたかもという人？
いいですね
結構いますね
はい ありがとうございます
じゃあ 目を開けてください
では 今皆さんが
想像していただいたことを
ぜひ舞台に上がって
みんなに発表いただける方
手を挙げてください
ちょっと...　あ！
まさか 手を挙げる人がいると
思ってなかったです
ありがとうございます
ご協力ありがとうございます
何かざわざわざわってしたと
思うんですけど
皆さんの中で
今 何が起きましたか？
「いや 菱谷さん
そんなの恥ずかしいよ」
「こういう場でそういうこと
言うことじゃないんじゃない？」
どこからともなく声が聞こえて
手を挙げようとする自分を抑えた
そんなことが
あったんじゃないでしょうか？
例えば  学生さんだったら
オンライン授業中に教授が
明らかに違うページの話を
しちゃってるよっていうときに
指摘しようかしまいか
迷うときありますよね？
そうだな 例えば
関東のネズミが出てくる
テーマパークで 舞台から
「お客様の中から舞台に上がってきて
協力してください」っていうときに
「いや 挙げたいけど 挙げたくない
どうしよう？」っていう葛藤わかりますか？
「うん うん うん」ってね
皆さん ありがとうございます
そういった 自分自身がやろうとしたこと
言おうとしたことに
ギューっと力が入って 抑える感じ
これを私は「自分らしさに
フタをする」と呼んでます
そして働くという場で
このように自分らしさにフタをして
苦しんでいる人を
たくさん見てきました
お金や評価のためには
我慢しなきゃいけない
そして合理的なこと以外は
言っちゃいけない
そして長らくそんなことをしていると
「働くってそういうもんだから」って
受け入れて
次第に周りに
こう言うようになるんですね
「我慢しなきゃ
働くってそういうもんだからさ」
皆さんいかがですか？
周りにそういう人いませんか？
います？
「うん うん うん」って
ありがとうございます　そうですね
でもちょっとした時間だったら
よくないですか？
今ぐらいの一瞬の
「挙げようかな」と迷うくらい
ただ働くって時間 どのぐらいだか
皆さん知ってます？
約９万時間です
この人生の大半を占める時間を
ずっと自分らしさにフタをして
生きていくこと
皆さんは受け入れることができますか？
ぜひ考えてみてください
世の中には どうやら
こういったことを全く受け入れることが
できない青年もいるようなんですね
２番目に笑うところなんですけどね
学生時代の私です
どう考えても合理的なようには
見えないですね
やりたいことをやって
時間を忘れて没頭して
非合理的なことばっかやってる
ただエネルギーにあふれて
すごい幸せだったなって私は思うんですね
皆さんもいかがですか？
そういった時はありませんか？
じゃ こういった青年が
社会に出るとどうなるか？
めちゃくちゃフタしちゃうんですね
めちゃくちゃフタしちゃうんですよ
お金 評価 成長 将来のために
「今は我慢 我慢 我慢」って
言い聞かせてフタしちゃう
そして悩んだ時に周りに相談すると
こう言われるんですね
「仕方ないよ　働くって
そういうもんだからさ」って
皆さん これ受け入れることできますか？
私はこのことに対して
受け入れることができませんでした
そして人生をかけて
これらを試して
そして実践してきました
［働く］
［自分らしさ］
この両極端に見える
「働く」と「自分らしさ」
どうしたら重なるのか？
それを私は試してきたんです
そして今どうやらこの瞬間
「自分らしく働けてるな」って
少なくとも以前よりは
実感してるんですね
じゃあ どうしたら
これが重なることができたのか？
それは私は「志」だと思ってます
「志」とは 人生をかけて
成し遂げたいこと
人生の目的とか
ミッションと言うかもしれません
それを持ってから私は自分らしく働くって
いうことを実感できているように感じます
でもこんなこと言うと
一番前の方もそうだと思うんですけど
「いや 志を持つのはわかってるよ」
「持った方がいいんでしょ」
「持てないから
困ってるんじゃないですか？」ってね
今たぶん大半の人が私にメッセージを
送ってくれてるんですけども
そういった皆さんのために
今日は私の経験を通して
３つの学びをご紹介したいと思います
そして どうしたら
志を持つことができるのか
そして育てることができるのか
ご紹介したいと思います
学びの１つ目 それは
「志は『何のため』から始まる」と
いうことです
皆さん
学生の方であれば
何のために学んでますか？
社会人の方
何のために働いていますか？
そして何のために生きていますか？
私はこの「何のため」という問いに
真正面から向き合うことで
この志というのは
始まるんじゃないかなと思っています
私も３年前
社会人５年目ですね
この「何のため」という問いに
真正面からぶつかる経験がありました
それまでは「成長のため
我慢 我慢 我慢」と言い聞かせて
ずっと働いてきました
ただ 結婚して 子どもが生まれて
大切なものが他にできるっていう
タイミングで
ごまかしがきかなくなって
ある問いがずっと繰り返し
流れてきたんですね
「人生の大半を占める働くっていうのが
こんなにつまんないの？
そしたら人生ってめちゃくちゃ
つまんなくない？」って
「だったら何のために働いてんの？
何のために生きてんの？」って
この問いがずっと私の中に
反復して流れたんだね
そこで私は答えが見いだせなかった
なので試行錯誤を始めました
２年かかりました
最初は「このつらい仕事を
いかに少なくしよう」とか
「ネットビジネスで
不労所得を得よう」とか
でも何か自分らしさを感じないんです
いや １回きりの人生だから有名になろう
VRっていう最新技術を使って
カッコよくなろう
何か自分らしくないんすよ
で いよいよ出会えます
最終的に 私は
私が人生で一番苦しかった
働くという時間が
一人でも多くの人が
自分らしく生き生きと働ける
そんな社会になったらいいな
自分らしく働くことができる人が
一人でも多く増えたらいいな
それが私の志になりました
ぜひ皆さんも 今取り組んでいること
勉強 そして働くこと 仕事
そして何のために
生きているかっていうのを
自分自身に聞いてみてください
そして答えが見いだせなければ
ぜひ試行錯誤を 小さくていいから
始めてみてください
必ずその先に 志は見えてくるはずです
ただ そんなことを言うと
また一番前の席の人 メッセージを
送っていただいてるんですけど
「いや菱谷さん
菱谷さんみたいに苦労したから
特別な経験したから
志が見えてきたんでしょ」
「私 学生だから そんなの
わかりませんよ」っていう人
メッセージを送っている方が
いると思いますけど
私は今はそう思いません
ここにいるすべての人に
志はあると思ってます
学びの２ですね
「志の根っこには悩みがある」と
思っています
私の志が確信に変わった瞬間があります
それは過去を振り返った時です
そしたら幼少期からどうやら
この志持ってたような感じがするんですね
小学校の時にサッカー少年団で
自分らしくプレーして
得点した時に 監督から
「お前はチームの方針と違うから
レギュラーから外れろ」と言われた時とか
中学の時に友達の中に馴染めずに
ずっと自分らしさを押し殺して
朝ビクビクしながら登校する時とか
そういったことを思い返すと
その時から「自分らしさをわかってほしい」
そして「分かち合いたい」
そんな風に思ってたんだなって思います
そんなことを思うと
父親との経験も思い出せるんです
下は私じゃないですよ
これ父親ですね
２歳の時の私です
父親はすごく陽気で
尊敬する人なんですけども
いつも正論を言う人でした
「こうしなきゃ幸せになれないよ」
「和明 こうしろよ」
ただ 幼いながらに正しいことは
わかってたんですけど
何か寂しかったんですね
たぶんどうやら
「和明はどう思うんだ？」
「和明らしい意見を聞かせてほしい」
そんな言葉を待ってたのかなって
私は思います
皆さんも過去を振り返ってみてください
皆さんに起こる悩みっていうのは
わざわざ皆さんに何かを教えようとして
悩みが起きていると思います
ここから起きる悩みもそうだと思います
その悩みと向き合ってみてください
そして そこと向き合った時に
志の根っこというのが見えてくるはずです
そのようにして 私の志
小さなところから始まりました
何の形もなかった
ただ今となっては年間
個人の方にも 法人の方にも
多く たくさん貢献できるものに
なりつつあります
ここに来たのは 私一人じゃ
到底来ることができなかったと思います
学びの３つ目
「志は仲間と共に育つ」です
最初は何の根拠も形もないところから
始まるんですよ
本当に妄想です
ただ そこに一緒になって
試行錯誤をしてくれた
今日は来てくれてますね
共同代表で今やってる仲間とか
何か形が出来上がったときに
学生インターンとして一緒に関わってくれた
今日ここにも来てくれてますね
仲間とか
正直そういった仲間がいなければ
私の今の現実はないと思ってます
なので皆さんもぜひ
そういった根拠も合理性もないことを
一緒に語れる仲間を大事にしてください
そして小さくていいから
始めてみてください
もし この中に
「いや そんな仲間 僕にいません
私にいません」という人
私に連絡ください
私が１人目になります
一緒に試行錯誤しましょう
こういった形で 私は志と共に
自分らしく働くということを
今この瞬間も実感してます
ただ１個 予想外のことがあるんです
自分らしく働くってなったら
喜びも倍になったんですよ
ただ 苦しみも倍になりました
自分の作ったサービスが
なかなか受け入れられないときとか
チームから仲間が去っていく時
それは今まで以上に苦しいし
寂しいって感じます
ただ そんなことも含めて
すごく意味があると思います
そして幸せを感じてます
そんなのが私は自分らしく
働くってことなのかなって今は思います
皆さんもぜひ試してみてください
最後に 皆さんにお願いがあります
今 私が話したこと
すべて忘れてください
私が今話したのは 私らしい志
そして私らしい働き方 生き方です
私のように また他の誰かのように生きたって
皆さんらしくは なれっこないんです
皆さんは皆さんの志 そして
皆さんらしい働き方・生き方を探求して
そして試行錯誤をしてください
その答えは もうすでに
今ここにいる皆さんの中に
あると思います
ありがとうございました